- I'd like to order a private plane.
Destinations Miami, San Fran, Vegas, Foxb—
What is that noise?!
- It's easy money, and you barely have to play.
- Yeah, but Indianapolis?
- Beer me, Aaron!
[Crashing and fizzing]
- Looks like that one hit..."LaFloor." Hahahaha.
- Why is your body making those noises?
- I'm doing a laughing, Tom.
I'm happy! Turns out during the playoffs,
everyone else stays in Gridiron Heights and gets along.
Have a cold one.
- Why? To be relatable on late-night TV?
- Everyone's welcome. Isn't that right, Russ?
We also got catering.
- The Jets are happy to sponsor the offseason dance contest...
...for the 12th straight year!
[Cheering]
- I wish Super Bowl expectations were this low!
- Could've been worse.
- I love it here.
- Look, look, watch.
Du...falllll.
- It's all good. I'm about to be Kirk Cousins rich.
- Look, the kickers parade's starting.
- [Crowd:] It's OK, we blame Dak!
- Sorry we weren't here sooner.
We accidentally beat the Bucs.
- Is it really not all about winning?
- Yo, we're trying to rest for the playoffs that we're still in.
- Our...apologies...
- Losing sucks!
- Everyone, get them!
- [All:] Aaaaaah!
- So, uh...how...how's Davante?
- Oh, you, uh, didn't hear? We broke up.
- Oh, wow, that's...I'm sorry to hear that.
- Yeah, well, think he never got over an old flame.
Go to him, Aaron.
[Romantic music swells]
- But-
- I wouldn't be Derek Carr if I didn't love love.
Now, go to him before it's too late.